es waren einmal eine stadt in hessen
nicht zu groß und nicht zu klein
die zauberte ihren berühmtesten söhnen
einen palast auf einen berg den siegerin
welt nennen und die leute kommen von nah
und fern um ihn zu sehen
für jung und alt
es gibt angebote für kinder man kann
dinge anfassen ausprobieren selber
machen und es richtet sich aber auch an
erwachsene an touristen an
wissenschaftler an kulturinteressierte
und natürlich ein griff ins ein großer
ausstellungsbereich ist natürlich den
märchen der brüder grimm gewidmet hier
können besucher den froschkönig begegnen
oder hinter hecken das dornröschen
suchen
oder einen zauberspiegel befragen wer
ist die schönste im ganzen land
ich bin dir drin und bin noch ganz
berauscht vom gebäude her macht das
richtig spaß hier durchzulaufen also man
hat man merkt wie man selbst entdecken
mag
das lädt jede ecke lädt zum entdecken
ein
alle für kassen auf jeden fall erreichen
also alles in allem beeindruckend sehr
zu empfehlen
das museum präsentiert auch schätze zum
beispiel und 200 jahre alte erstdrucke
der kinder und hausmärchen sind
persönlicher exemplare der brüder grimm
versehen mit ihren notizen jacob grimm
wurde 1785 in hanau geboren und sein
bruder wilhelm ein jahr später zum
gymnasium kamen die brüder zur tante
nach kassel in der mitteldeutschen stadt
lebten sie mit unterbrechungen rund 30
jahre hier begangen sie auch mit dem
sammeln von märchen historischen auf das
was sie in ihrem leben geschaffen haben
das werk was
von ihnen unterblieben ist aber
natürlich auch auf die aktualität und
auf das was unsere heutige zeit bedeutet
vor allem ihrer arbeit als
sprachwissenschaftler wirkt bis heute
fort
die brüder grimm erforschten die
entwicklung der sprache und sie begannen
mit einem mammut werk den bis heute
größten und umfassendsten deutschen
wörterbuch doch es sind vor allem die
märchen die die kinder bis heute
faszinieren oder manchmal auch ein wenig
das fürchten lehren
es ist schon erstaunlich dass uns die
alten geschichten noch genauso
verzaubern wie zu grimms zeigen nur dass
man heute dank der technik bei den
sieben zwergen direkt am tisch setzen
kann und sie lebten glücklich und
zufrieden bis zu ihrem nächsten besuch
in der grimm welt kassel